actor Kevin Spacey is expected to appear
in a Massachusetts courtroom this
morning to face accusations of sexually
assaulting an 18 year old busboy on the
island of Nantucket the former house of
cards star says he'll plead not guilty
to one count of indecent assault and
battery investigators allege Spacey gave
the victim alcohol before repeatedly
groping him in public
Jericka Duncan is outside the district
court in Nantucket
Jericka good morning good morning as you
can imagine Kevin Spacey did not want to
appear at this arraignment but a judge
ordered him to be here he's expected to
walk through one of three entrances here
at this courthouse now the arraignment
is not expected to last long but as you
can imagine again Kevin Spacey this is
the first time the oscar-winning actor
will address a sexual assault charge
Kevin Spacey posted this video hours
after he was charged pushing back
against accusations of inappropriate
behavior you wouldn't rush to judgments
without facts would you Spacey has been
accused of sexual misconduct by several
men but only one accusation has resulted
in a criminal charge - Kevin Spacey I
want to say this shame on you
for what you did to my son former Boston
television anchor Heather Unruh says her
then 18 year old son met Spacey in July
of 2016 at a popular Nantucket bar
called the club car where he worked as a
busboy according to the criminal
complaint Unruh son told Spacey he was a
23 year old college student the two
exchanged cell phone numbers and Spacey
bought the accuser eight to ten drinks
in about 70 minutes the 59 year old who
was fired from house of cards in
November of 2017 I shall resign the
office of President of the United
allegedly assaulted the victim while the
two men stood shoulder-to-shoulder by a
piano space he stuck his hand inside my
son's pants and grabbed his genitals
this was completely unexpected
the accuser claimed space he groped him
for about three minutes and that he
captured part of the assault on a brief
snapchat video he later told a police
officer he fled while Spacey was in the
bathroom the officer was questioned by
Spacey's attorney at a court hearing
last month yes he found no witnesses to
corroborate his statement about the
three minutes worth of broken cracked
pepper CBS news legal analyst Ricky
Clayman I think the defense strongest
argument is that this was a consensual
act by someone who was pretending to be
of age so that Kevin Spacey had reason
to believe that all of this was a
consensual encounter the alleged victim
says that he immediately told his
younger sister the night of the incident
when he returned home right now we're
hearing that again Kevin Spacey could
face up to the five years if convicted
of this car of this crime Nora all right
Joe Rica thank you
disturbing details very disturbing and
many people confused about very confused
about Kevin Spacey's strategy that that
video that he released is so bizarre
where he appears to be playing the Frank
Underwood character it'll be interesting
to see what he says now although none of
this would have been come to better have
been known without the mother really
correctly working and defending her son
yeah